well joining me now to discuss this is
the General Secretary of the public and
Commercial Services Union Mark sawatka a
very good morning to you thank you for
joining us now of course you represent
uh the Border force staff striking uh
today and the dispute is overpay
pensions and conditions what is
currently on offer from the government
and what are your members demanding
uh well good morning and good morning
interviewers
um well we've been given the lowest
payoffer anywhere in the economy the
government's given its own Workforce a
two percent pay raise
we're asking for 10 uh we're asking that
because inflation is over 10 we've had
10 years where our pay has not cap rate
with inflation and currently the
government-owned staff
40 000 of them use food banks and forty
five thousand of them are so poor
they're the in-work poor they have to
claim the benefits that in some case
they administer themselves from job
centers so we have a crisis of poverty
in the Civil Service and in addition the
government is telling people they're
going to slash tens of thousands of
their jobs and cut their redundancy
terms by 30 no one else faces attacks on
this scale and these are the people the
government clapped in the pandemic for
paying three million claims to Universal
Credit delivering the furlough scheme
keeping our justice system running on
our borders secure so it's not good
enough to clap them in the pandemic and
they'll give them the lowest pay raise
anywhere in the economy
now the head of Passenger operations at
Gatwick Airport has told us this morning
that things are smooth there are you
concerned that if there isn't disruption
if that if possible control does remain
smooth in these six airports that you
won't have a way of really forcing the
government's hand to offer you more
no we'll see what happens across the
airports over the next few days that the
government's obviously gone to Great
cost to bring in the Army they're not
properly trained they're bringing people
in from all over the country to try and
paper over the cracks and the answer
isn't to try and paper over the cracks
or bring the Army in it's to recognize
that it's not sustainable to give us the
lowest payoff anywhere when such poverty
exists and then refuse to talk about the
issue of pay but what the government
knows is that so far we have had about 5
000 members on strike we've been on
strike in driving tests on our motorways
in the river payments agencies and in
some job centers but a hundred thousand
people have voted to go on strike and so
in January if the government still
refuse to talk despite what's going to
happen at our airports on our roads with
our driving tests and with payments to
Farmers the strike will escalate
significantly and I also believe other
public sector workers will make the same
choice we know that hundreds of
thousands of teachers for example are
currently about him for industrial
action and the answer to this is not
this disruption it's not to talk about
strikes is to get government ministers
to front up not be missing in action
talk about pay and let us get back to
providing the services that our members
want to be providing now we're already
hearing uh strike dates announced for
other sectors ambulance workers nurses
were expecting to hear about too
can we expect more strikes from border
four staff in January and what does
escalation look like when it comes to
your industrial action
so escalation for us I mean yesterday we
served notice to bring members out on
strike in the dvla which is going to
affect significantly the issue of
driving licenses for example but we also
have members who voted to strike who
issued passports people who work in
every major government Department
including our job center Network and our
benefits Network so a hundred thousand
people are voted to strike all of them
are struggling all of them are poorer at
the end of the year than they were at
the start even though they worked harder
than ever before so escalation in the
Civil Service will mean every government
Department begins to be affected and
within the home office itself at the
moment we've called out staff in the
airports but of course there are other
areas like Dover for example and other
ports across the UK that members would
be called out to take strike action on
but I hope none of that happens and I
hope a government Minister comes on to
explain why is their own Workforce are
living in poverty and they will not give
them a penny above 2 percent which is
not what they're saying to anybody else
in the economy
well it's it's quite clear that the
government is not going to be offering
an 11 pay rise what compromise would you
accept
well we've asked for 10
um and we've asked for assurances there
won't be redundancies I mean your
viewers may be amazed to know that
there's over a thousand people working
in the job centers at the moment facing
redundancies even though you need more
people delivering welfare and a cost of
living crisis than ever before if the
government says they'll put money on the
table we are prepared to negotiate where
that goes who gets it when and where and
how quickly they get it but we want
money now because the crisis is now we
are not saying it's 10 or we won't talk
to you we're saying put money on the
table and we are prepared to negotiate
but the government will not do that and
they keep hiding behind this claim that
is independent paid of their bodies but
they know there is no independent pay of
anybody in the Civil Service they've
chosen to give their own Workforce the
lowest pay raise of any part of the
economy and that is not acceptable
now National highways staff are also on
strike today the first of four days of
industrial action they're also members
of your union what's your message uh to
people trying to get home for Christmas
who are now really worried about their
plans having had a really tough couple
of years with covid and now facing this
disruption at the border on the roads
what would you say to them
well what I say to them and also the
people whose driving tests have been
canceled and the farmers who are
struggling to get payments from the
rural payments agency is the government
we're told six months ago that this was
going to happen they were told three
weeks ago that these particular strikes
were going to happen and yet they have
not agreed to have a single meeting with
us all agreed to put a single penny on
the table so anyone who faces disruption
you have a right to be angry but your
anger should be directed at Richie sunac
and Jeremy Hunt they could stop these
strikes today they are choosing not to
that is a disgraceful way to treat some
of the hardest working men and women in
this country and if they maintain that
stance these strikes will only grow and
escalate I don't want to see that but
what I do want to see is an end to end
with poverty and only the government can
end that by giving us the pay raise we
deserve
uh now soldiers and civil servants who
are Manning uh passport control at
airports today have had reportedly
around five days of training for this
what are your members who work for
Border Force saying about the problems
that could arise from that
well we all know and and so Ella
Braverman knows uh that giving people
five days training uh is no substitute
for the skilled job that our members do
because this is not just about checking
passports these are people who are
trained over many months and years on on
the job training to be able to deal with
issues at the passport control including
for example looking out for victims of
people trafficking looking out for
people in a vulnerable situation looking
out for people who may not be all that
they seem and that takes skill takes
skill to spot it and skill to deal with
it having squatties turn up with no
training to paper over the cracks is not
the answer and what the government needs
to ask itself is it's got military
personnel driving ambulances and now at
our borders are they going to teach our
children Drive our chain trains pay
Universal Credit collect our taxes of
course they can't the Army is no
substitute for public sector workers we
all know this and we also all know that
the government could end this today and
I'll make this final point point
what we're asking for is a tiny fraction
of what the government was prepared to
borrow to give tax cuts to the richest
people in Britain if they were prepared
to do that for the richest why can't
they find a fraction of the money for
Job Center workers border force staff
rural payments agency staff paramedics
nurses and train workers we deserve it
the public know that we deserve it yet
the government has gone missing in
action and they are to blame for the
disruption